special thanks to athletic greens the
ultimate all-in-one nutritional
supplement for supporting this video
please see the link in the description
to learn more
what is egg boxing so it's a sport
slash game where whenever you're making
something with eggs you you hold an egg
you hold another egg you bang them off
each other the one that cracks you
obviously break and the one that didn't
crack
that's considered one win so that like
let's say these are two eggs you've
never touched before
you smash them that guy is now 1-0
and then you pick up another egg let's
say you want to make five eggs and you
smash
and let's say that guy wins again so
he's now 2-0
and then you smash again and let's say
he loses well then he retires with a
record of two and one and the other guy
is now 1-0 and you keep going
and at the end like when you break your
last egg that day you write down how
many wins
the last guy has because by definition
the last one standing is always the
winner and then the next time you come
to make eggs you just play again
and so i don't know when i started
playing this game but it was somewhere
in high school
and i've never stopped and i take it
very seriously
and i guard the champion very closely
and as you're alluding to we did we did
there was there was one very very
special egg in my life
in 2007 and 2008 who i nicknamed
ramanujan after the great mathematician
not a great boxer but
he was such a prodigy boxer yeah
but uh he's the only egg i've ever had
where his winning record was so
great that we i lost track of his actual
record
was it in the hundreds thousands oh
i mean put it this way he was the
champion for more than a year
now all right we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna continue
on to future bullets but i i will say if
my memory serves me correctly that at
one point you were like i want to know
what type of strange like abscess or
like structural abnormality exists in
this egg
but you couldn't get someone to agree to
x-ray the egg for you so you like snuck
it into your pocket
well no the plan was i was gonna go to
the er and pretend i had a groin injury
and have them do a ct scan of my pelvis
with ramune in my pocket because i
wanted to see
what was really going on inside of him
and alas we shall never know
i get asked all the time what i would
take if i could only take
one supplement the answer is invariably
athletic greens
i view it as all-in-one nutritional
insurance i recommended it
in fact in the four hour body this is
more than ten years ago
and i did not get paid to do so with
approximately 75 vitamins
minerals and whole foods sourced
ingredients you'd be very hard pressed
to find a more nutrient dense and
comprehensive formula
on the market it has multi vitamins
multi-mineral greens complex
probiotics and prebiotics for gut health
and immunity formula digestive enzymes
adaptogens and much more i usually take
it once
or twice a day just to make sure i've
covered my bases
if i miss anything i'm not aware of of
course i
focus on nutrient-dense meals to begin
with that's the basis
but athletic greens makes it easy to get
a lot of nutrition when whole foods
aren't readily available
from travel packets i always have them
in my bag
when i'm zipping around it's also nsf
certified for sport making it safe for
competitive athletes
as what's on the label is in the powder
it is the ultimate all-in-one
nutritional supplement bundle
in one easy scoop and right now athletic
greens is giving my audience that's you
guys
a special offer on top of their
all-in-one formula which is a free
vitamin d supplement with your first
subscription purchase many of us are
deficient in vitamin d
which is usually produced in our bodies
from sun exposure so
particularly in the winter months adding
a vitamin d supplement to your daily
routine is a great option for additional
immune support
make an investment in your health today
and try the ultimate all-in-one wellness
bundle support your immunity gut health
and energy by
visiting athleticgreens.com tfs
you'll receive up to a year's supply of
vitamin d for free with your first
subscription purchase
again that's athleticgreens.com
tfs as in tim ferriss show
athleticgreens.com tfs